welcome to this video this is a very
different video I'm SI Justin came
across the news story here in this case
the video is showing it on chest calm
but it also has been on some other chess
related websites there has been on an
urgent appeal by on Georgian
International Master bilious aluminum
and she's the mother of a four month old
daughter who's got a very serious
disease heart disease and she doesn't
have the money to to pay them necessary
operation that might save from the life
of a daughter and it's a very costly
operation sixty thousand euros if it is
some performed in Germany it would even
be more expensive it was done in the US
I don't really know that the details is
just briefly mentioned here in this
article so what she's doing is some
she's trying to raise money to to be
able to afford this possibly life-saving
operation um that's also a video here
I'll also post the link you can see at
the end the video but I also post the
link so that you don't have to retype it
or just go to chest commenter look unuse
it's in there so on GM gave an account
number here where you can donate money
but there isn't dumb people account or
something so what is some I mean I work
in banking and transferring money to 2am
the foreign bank account is quite a
difficult operation sometimes it's also
very costly so let's say you you cannot
afford to donate huge amounts of money
and you just want to donate five dollars
or something then you would pay a
multitude of five dollars for just doing
the bank transfer so it's very difficult
to
to donate small amounts also I
remembered that when I took two days ago
I posted a video about this channel how
it will I'm development and thinks
people actually offered to donate money
to me and thanks thanking me for doing
this this channel and they asked me if I
had ever had a paypal account where they
can send money to and said the red don't
really need it and so on but when i came
across the story i remembered that
people actually suggested to him
goodnight to me and so i'll make a
proposition here on this channel um if
you first of all you can of course the
red donate directly to this bank account
here on this mention on the website and
send it directly to her but do an
alternative often here and if you send
um or donate money to my paypal account
which i will also post in the
description and also will be Brittany in
the video let's see underscore zolecki
my name Adam freenet dot de I will put
it to put it in the video if you donate
money to me I will make sure to send
this money in one batch ok I'll also of
course take care of the costs for the
bank transfer I'll pass on this this
whole a whole bunch of money that will
be collected in my paypal account a loop
i'll pass this on to the nato to this
good course and i will also add
substantial amount of firm of my own to
this to this figure a thought of
offering to match every dollar every
euro that you donate with one dollar of
mine but this might bring me get me in
trouble i hope i hope that you have some
money to spare for this good cause so i
will match your donation some within
reason i cannot afford to donate
thousands of dollars but i can i can do
a little bit of
thing as well yeah I hope you um have
the ability to help here think it's one
of the beautiful things of the internet
that the community in this case the
chest community can can reach lots of
people within them yeah with the
internet to to help with such causes
this is really something that would have
been unthinkable like 20 years ago and I
hope something good gets out of this
it's not a given that this operation
actually would would solve this this
this disease this is hard problems but
it the only chance that this little
child obviously has so um yeah I think
about my offer I will of course also
tell you what will come out of this and
I promised some within reason to add my
my own money to them to the donated
money of course if you can afford and
know the the the ins and outs of those
international bankers first just feel
free to to donate it directly but I'm
thinking about the persons who actually
offered me some some dollars so now's
the chance give me the money and I'll
pass it on to this good course and add
something on my own yeah thanks for
watching and make sure to to check the
link that I'm posting and and also she
also explained a situational video this
is all in the link so have a look at
this and think about if you can can help
this good cause thanks